This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There is so much to do at the mall. You can get your ears pierced. You can build a bear. You can go get an orange Julius. Late at night, when the Game Stops and the hot topics are all locked up and the food court's taken out the last of the trash, it is usually time to go home. But what if the mall was your home? This ad came on for the Proppments Place Mall. It was this woman talking about how it was going to be so convenient for her to get everything that she needed for her kids, for herself.
This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There is so much to do at the mall. You can get your ears pierced. You can build a bear. You can go get an orange Julius. Late at night, when the Game Stops and the hot topics are all locked up and the food court's taken out the last of the trash, it is usually time to go home. But what if the mall was your home? This ad came on for the Proppments Place Mall. It was this woman talking about how it was going to be so convenient for her to get everything that she needed for her kids, for herself.|||这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马斯。商场里有太多事情可做了。你可以去穿耳洞。你可以自己做一个泰迪熊。你可以去买一杯橙色朱利斯。深夜时分，“游戏驿站”打烊，热门话题店统统上锁，美食广场倒掉了最后一袋垃圾，通常就该回家了。但如果商场就是你的家呢？当时播放了一则普罗维登斯广场购物中心的广告。广告里有个女人在谈论，在那里买齐她和孩子们需要的所有东西会有多方便。
If only she could live there. I just had this idea, oh, we should live in the mall. The new documentary, Secret Mall Apartment, is about a group of artists who built, you guessed it, a secret apartment inside of the mall. We interviewed the group's ringleader, Michael Townsend, a few years back, and after the story, we'll have an update
If only she could live there. I just had this idea, oh, we should live in the mall. The new documentary, Secret Mall Apartment, is about a group of artists who built, you guessed it, a secret apartment inside of the mall. We interviewed the group's ringleader, Michael Townsend, a few years back, and after the story, we'll have an update|||要是她能住在那里就好了。我当时就冒出了这个想法，哦，我们应该住在商场里。这部名为《商场里的秘密公寓》的新纪录片讲述了一群艺术家，正如你所料，在商场里建造了一间秘密公寓的故事。几年前，我们采访了该团伙的头目迈克尔·汤森，在讲完这个故事后，我们将带来最新进展。
about what's happened since then. In downtown Providence, Rhode Island, there's a large plot of land that sits on the bank of the Wunosquaducket River. In 1838, it was the home of the Rhode Island State Prison, which was notorious for its horrid smell, dreary outward appearance, and reputation for solitary confinement. Later, the land housed the continuing education campus for the University of Rhode Island. And after that, a dirt parking lot called Ray's Park and Lock. Then in 1999, in a grand effort to revitalize the city and with much fanfare, the Providence Place Mall was opened.
about what's happened since then. In downtown Providence, Rhode Island, there's a large plot of land that sits on the bank of the Wunosquaducket River. In 1838, it was the home of the Rhode Island State Prison, which was notorious for its horrid smell, dreary outward appearance, and reputation for solitary confinement. Later, the land housed the continuing education campus for the University of Rhode Island. And after that, a dirt parking lot called Ray's Park and Lock. Then in 1999, in a grand effort to revitalize the city and with much fanfare, the Providence Place Mall was opened.|||关于自那以后发生了什么。在罗德岛州普罗维登斯市中心，有一大片土地坐落在乌诺斯夸杜克特河畔。1838年，这里曾是罗德岛州立监狱所在地，该监狱以恶臭熏天、外表阴森以及关押单人牢房而臭名昭著。后来，这块土地成了罗德岛大学的继续教育校区。再后来，这里变成了一个名为“雷的停车锁”的泥土地停车场。接着在1999年，为了重振这座城市，在盛大的欢呼声中，普罗维登斯广场购物中心盛大开业了。
That's Vanessa Lowe, producer of the podcast Nocturne. The mall, costing $500 million, was what was known as a super-regional, a one-stop shopping destination, housing everything consumers could possibly want or need in a totally enclosed space. Partially funded by taxpayer money, it spanned 13 acres, offered 1.4 million square feet of retail space, and dominated the riverfront. It was the largest construction project in Providence's history. Oh, this one building, and we sort of stood in awe watching it get built.
That's Vanessa Lowe, producer of the podcast Nocturne. The mall, costing $500 million, was what was known as a super-regional, a one-stop shopping destination, housing everything consumers could possibly want or need in a totally enclosed space. Partially funded by taxpayer money, it spanned 13 acres, offered 1.4 million square feet of retail space, and dominated the riverfront. It was the largest construction project in Providence's history. Oh, this one building, and we sort of stood in awe watching it get built.|||说话的是播客《夜曲》的制作人凡妮莎·洛。这座耗资5亿美元的商场被称为超级区域性商场，是一个一站式购物目的地，在一个完全封闭的空间里容纳了消费者可能想要或需要的一切。它部分资金由纳税人资助，占地13英亩，拥有140万平方英尺的零售空间，占据了整个河滨。这是普罗维登斯历史上最大的建筑项目。哦，就这么一栋建筑，我们当时有点敬畏地看着它拔地而起。
Michael Townsend is an artist who lived nearby when the mall was still under construction in the 1990s. His daily running route took him past the construction site. And Michael says that as he watched it go up, he had an open mind about the project. He was cautiously optimistic that it would be a welcome addition to the neighborhood. But yeah, that didn't last long. It's funny, the revulsion to a building like that doesn't really kick in until the skin gets put on.
Michael Townsend is an artist who lived nearby when the mall was still under construction in the 1990s. His daily running route took him past the construction site. And Michael says that as he watched it go up, he had an open mind about the project. He was cautiously optimistic that it would be a welcome addition to the neighborhood. But yeah, that didn't last long. It's funny, the revulsion to a building like that doesn't really kick in until the skin gets put on.|||迈克尔·汤森是一位艺术家，20世纪90年代商场还在建设时，他就住在附近。他日常的跑步路线会经过施工现场。迈克尔说，当他看着它建起来时，他对这个项目抱持开放的心态。他谨慎地乐观认为，它会成为社区受欢迎的新成员。但是，好吧，这并没有持续多久。说来也搞笑，对这种建筑的厌恶感，直到它穿上“外衣”时才真正爆发出来。
When something is in its erector set mode, when you're just seeing the skeleton, you're like, oh, that's a pretty cool skeleton, but as soon as the flesh is there, you're like, ooh, not pretty. Providence Place was going to be a big boxy stack of shops without much in the way of architectural niceties. And on his runs, Michael watched as that big box
When something is in its erector set mode, when you're just seeing the skeleton, you're like, oh, that's a pretty cool skeleton, but as soon as the flesh is there, you're like, ooh, not pretty. Providence Place was going to be a big boxy stack of shops without much in the way of architectural niceties. And on his runs, Michael watched as that big box|||当某个东西还处于拼插玩具模式、当你只看到它的骨架时，你会觉得，哦，这个骨架挺酷的；但一旦有了“血肉”，你就会觉得，呃，不好看。普罗维登斯广场将是一个方方正正的商店堆砌体，没有什么建筑美感可言。在跑步的过程中，迈克尔看着那个大盒子……
was slowly filled with the things that make a mall a mall. As it's being built, I start to sort of do mental maps of spaces. You know, that's going to be a store, that's going to be a storage space, that's going to be parking. But amidst all the construction, there was one part of the building that kept catching Michael's eye. A weird space in the guts of the architecture
was slowly filled with the things that make a mall a mall. As it's being built, I start to sort of do mental maps of spaces. You know, that's going to be a store, that's going to be a storage space, that's going to be parking. But amidst all the construction, there was one part of the building that kept catching Michael's eye. A weird space in the guts of the architecture|||慢慢被那些让商场成为商场的东西填满。在它建造的过程中，我开始在脑海里绘制空间的心理地图。你知道的，那将是一家商店，那将是一个储藏空间，那将是停车场。但在所有的建设当中，建筑内部有一个地方一直吸引着迈克尔的目光。那是建筑核心区域的一个奇怪空间，
That didn't make sense. I Thought that was really odd. It didn't seem to meet the profile of either a storage space or a parking space or store space Michael wasn't sure what the space was for it seemed to exist only by virtue of the walls Intended for the more legitimate spaces around it. But the result was this room. It was an accidental room, a remainder left over by the long division of the mall's architecture. I had never seen anything like it. And every time I ran by it, it was something that I would think about. Michael eventually put the strange room out of his mind.
That didn't make sense. I Thought that was really odd. It didn't seem to meet the profile of either a storage space or a parking space or store space Michael wasn't sure what the space was for it seemed to exist only by virtue of the walls Intended for the more legitimate spaces around it. But the result was this room. It was an accidental room, a remainder left over by the long division of the mall's architecture. I had never seen anything like it. And every time I ran by it, it was something that I would think about. Michael eventually put the strange room out of his mind.|||这说不通。我觉得这真的很奇怪。它既不符合储藏空间、停车空间，也不符合商店空间的轮廓。迈克尔不确定这个空间是用来做什么的，它似乎仅仅因为周围那些更合规空间所需的墙壁而自然存在。但结果就是这样一个房间。这是一个意外的房间，是商场建筑长久分割后留下的剩余空间。我从未见过这样的东西。而且每次我从它旁边跑过，我都会想起它。迈克尔最终把这个奇怪的房间抛到了脑后。
He probably would have forgotten about it entirely, except that four years later, a second group of developers, encouraged by the success of Providence Place, set their sights even closer to Michael. This time, they wanted to build right on top of the historic Mill District, where Michael and a dozen or so other artists lived and worked in an old industrial building they called Fort Thunder. The developers had used a
He probably would have forgotten about it entirely, except that four years later, a second group of developers, encouraged by the success of Providence Place, set their sights even closer to Michael. This time, they wanted to build right on top of the historic Mill District, where Michael and a dozen or so other artists lived and worked in an old industrial building they called Fort Thunder. The developers had used a|||他可能已经把它忘得精光了，直到四年后，第二批开发商受到普罗维登斯广场成功的鼓舞，将目光投向了距离迈克尔更近的地方。这一次，他们想直接在历史悠久的磨坊区上方大兴土木，迈克尔和其他十多位艺术家就在那里的一栋名为“雷霆堡”的旧工业建筑里生活和工作。开发商使用了一个……
computer algorithm to figure out where to place a new supermarket so that it wouldn't compete with other supermarkets in the area. And I got to see this computer print out and it's sort of like a nuclear explosion map. You can sort of see the radius from each supermarket and their theoretical reach. And in the blank spot that was our neighborhood, they put an X directly on the building we were living. And that was just the start. The developers wanted to tear down all of the old mill buildings and replace them with yet more retail with little to no pedestrian access. And it appears that the only mantra they have is if you see a space that's underdeveloped,
computer algorithm to figure out where to place a new supermarket so that it wouldn't compete with other supermarkets in the area. And I got to see this computer print out and it's sort of like a nuclear explosion map. You can sort of see the radius from each supermarket and their theoretical reach. And in the blank spot that was our neighborhood, they put an X directly on the building we were living. And that was just the start. The developers wanted to tear down all of the old mill buildings and replace them with yet more retail with little to no pedestrian access. And it appears that the only mantra they have is if you see a space that's underdeveloped,|||计算机算法来计算新超市应该放在哪里，这样它就不会与该地区的其他超市竞争。我有幸看到了这个计算机打印件，它有点像核爆炸地图。你可以看到每个超市的半径以及它们的理论辐射范围。而在我们社区所在的空白地带，他们在我们居住的建筑物上直接打了个“X”。而这仅仅是个开始。开发商想要拆除所有旧磨坊建筑，用更多的零售店取而代之，且几乎不提供人行通道。他们唯一的信条似乎就是：如果你看到一个未充分开发的地区，
you have a God-given responsibility to develop it. And it was basically like having a complete stranger be like, we've been thinking about it and we think we want to knock your house down and make it a parking lot if it's cool with you. Now normally this would be the part of the story where we tell you that Michael and the other residents of Fort Thunder banded together to save their home in the face of the relentless march of capital, but no it's not that kind of story. Granted they did save some buildings, but as for Fort Thunder…
you have a God-given responsibility to develop it. And it was basically like having a complete stranger be like, we've been thinking about it and we think we want to knock your house down and make it a parking lot if it's cool with you. Now normally this would be the part of the story where we tell you that Michael and the other residents of Fort Thunder banded together to save their home in the face of the relentless march of capital, but no it's not that kind of story. Granted they did save some buildings, but as for Fort Thunder…|||你就有上帝赋予的责任去开发它。这基本上就像是一个完全陌生的路人对你说：“我们考虑过了，如果我们觉得行的话，想把你家砸了改建成停车场。”通常情况下，故事讲到这里，我们会告诉你，面对资本的无情推进，迈克尔和“雷霆堡”的其他居民团结起来保卫家园，但不是的，这不是那种类型的故事。诚然，他们确实挽救了一些建筑，但至于“雷霆堡”……
Oh, our actual home? Oh yeah, they f***ing leveled that. They came in with bulldozers and cranes and knocked that sucker flat. Fort Thunder was gone. The reason we're telling you this story is because of what happened next. Because, when I see something like that, I'm like, ho ho ho, really? Game on. Michael and his friends had lost their home. And in their mind, it had all started with that first mall.
Oh, our actual home? Oh yeah, they f***ing leveled that. They came in with bulldozers and cranes and knocked that sucker flat. Fort Thunder was gone. The reason we're telling you this story is because of what happened next. Because, when I see something like that, I'm like, ho ho ho, really? Game on. Michael and his friends had lost their home. And in their mind, it had all started with that first mall.|||哦，我们真正的家？哦，对啊，他们把那玩意儿给平了。他们开着推土机和起重机进来，把那个倒霉地方砸成了平地。“雷霆堡”没了。我们之所以给你讲这个故事，是因为接下来发生的事情。因为，当我看到这样的事情时，我会想：哦？真的吗？那我们走着瞧。迈克尔和他的朋友们失去了家园。在他们看来，这一切都始于最初的那家商场。
That was the original seed of development that had led to everything else. And so talk began of a mall-related action. Call it art, call it a stunt, but a plan started to take shape. Michael and his friends decided that they would find a way to live in the mall for seven days. Yeah, live in the mall.
That was the original seed of development that had led to everything else. And so talk began of a mall-related action. Call it art, call it a stunt, but a plan started to take shape. Michael and his friends decided that they would find a way to live in the mall for seven days. Yeah, live in the mall.|||那是导致这一切的开发的最初种子。于是，关于一项与商场有关的行动的讨论开始了。你可以称之为艺术，也可以称之为噱头，但一个计划开始成形。迈克尔和他的朋友们决定，他们要找个方法在商场里住上七天。没错，住在商场里。
And they set a rule for themselves. They couldn't leave. And without a second thought of thinking about how unfeasible that is, for our own well-being, we really felt that we had to do it. And if this sounds like a lark, well, yeah, it kinda was, but a secretly serious lark. The four friends, they would eventually number eight,
And they set a rule for themselves. They couldn't leave. And without a second thought of thinking about how unfeasible that is, for our own well-being, we really felt that we had to do it. And if this sounds like a lark, well, yeah, it kinda was, but a secretly serious lark. The four friends, they would eventually number eight,|||他们给自己定了一条规矩：不能离开。而且没有多想这有多么不可行，为了我们自己的心理健康，我们真的觉得自己必须这么做。如果这听起来像是一场恶作剧，好吧，是的，确实有点像，但这是一场暗中严肃的恶作剧。这四个朋友——他们最终增加到了八个人——
wanted to assert that spaces like the mall could belong just as much to them as to the developers. To really do this right, they would need to find a space in the mall where they could hide themselves away. And Michael had the perfect place in mind. He began to search for that mysterious room that he'd noticed when the mall was under construction all those years before.
wanted to assert that spaces like the mall could belong just as much to them as to the developers. To really do this right, they would need to find a space in the mall where they could hide themselves away. And Michael had the perfect place in mind. He began to search for that mysterious room that he'd noticed when the mall was under construction all those years before.|||想要宣称，像商场这样的空间不仅属于开发商，也同样可以属于他们。要想真正做好这件事，他们需要在商场里找到一个可以把自己藏起来的空间。迈克尔心里有个完美的地方。他开始寻找那个神秘的房间，也就是多年前商场建设时他注意到的那个房间。
He remembered seeing that the room was connected to a kind of crevice, a narrow gap in the building structure that eventually led out to an exterior wall. So one night, Michael went to see if the entrance to that crevice had ever been sealed off. Amazingly, it hadn't. It was small and sort of hidden, but there was still a crack in the exterior of the mall. And so he and his then-wife Adriana turned themselves sideways and slipped inside. And then once you're in at that point, you are exploring a system of caverns, long, weird, vertical caverns. And there are places where it just falls down into the lower levels of
He remembered seeing that the room was connected to a kind of crevice, a narrow gap in the building structure that eventually led out to an exterior wall. So one night, Michael went to see if the entrance to that crevice had ever been sealed off. Amazingly, it hadn't. It was small and sort of hidden, but there was still a crack in the exterior of the mall. And so he and his then-wife Adriana turned themselves sideways and slipped inside. And then once you're in at that point, you are exploring a system of caverns, long, weird, vertical caverns. And there are places where it just falls down into the lower levels of|||他记得那个房间连接着一条裂缝，那是建筑结构中一个狭窄的空隙，最终通向外墙。于是有一天晚上，迈克尔去查看那条裂缝的入口是否被封死。令人惊奇的是，并没有。它很小，有点隐蔽，但商场外墙上依然留有一道裂缝。于是他和当时的妻子阿德里亚娜侧着身子溜了进去。一旦你进到里面，你就在探索一个洞穴系统，长而诡异的垂直洞穴。有些地方它会直接通往……
the mall. So you've got about a foot and a half of cliff, but you're looking into a black abyss. And then this series of chambers ultimately give you access to this space. The room was tall and wide, filled with the byproducts of the mall's construction from years before. Broken two by fours and screws and plastic zip ties
the mall. So you've got about a foot and a half of cliff, but you're looking into a black abyss. And then this series of chambers ultimately give you access to this space. The room was tall and wide, filled with the byproducts of the mall's construction from years before. Broken two by fours and screws and plastic zip ties|||商场的底层。所以你面前大约有一英尺半的悬崖，而你正凝视着一个黑色的深渊。接着，这一系列房间最终让你能够通往这个空间。这个房间又高又宽，里面堆满了多年前商场建设时遗留下的废料。断裂的二乘四木方、螺丝和塑料扎带，
that hadn't even been worth removing. The space had literally been forgotten. And it was big. It was a big space that served no other purpose. It wasn't a storefront and it wasn't a stairwell. It was just big and it was a thrill to physically find it and be like, this is it. This is what I remember.
that hadn't even been worth removing. The space had literally been forgotten. And it was big. It was a big space that served no other purpose. It wasn't a storefront and it wasn't a stairwell. It was just big and it was a thrill to physically find it and be like, this is it. This is what I remember.|||甚至都不值得清理出去。这个空间简直被人遗忘了。而且它很大。这是一个没有其他用途的大空间。它既不是店面，也不是楼梯间。它只是很大，亲眼找到它时那种刺激感油然而生，心里想着：就是这里。这就是我记忆中的那个地方。
The room was in the guts of the building. The part that no one was ever supposed to use or even really see. But Michael and Adriana saw that it could still be accessed by multiple hidden entry points, including from inside the shopping center itself. If you knew how to get there, you could walk there from the Macy's. But as far as they could tell, they were the only people who knew this room existed.
The room was in the guts of the building. The part that no one was ever supposed to use or even really see. But Michael and Adriana saw that it could still be accessed by multiple hidden entry points, including from inside the shopping center itself. If you knew how to get there, you could walk there from the Macy's. But as far as they could tell, they were the only people who knew this room existed.|||这个房间位于建筑的核心深处。那是任何人都绝不应该使用、甚至根本不应该看到的区域。但迈克尔和阿德里亚娜发现，通过多个隐蔽的入口依然可以进入它，包括从购物中心内部进入。如果你知道怎么走，你可以从梅西百货一路走过去。但据他们所知，他们是唯一知道这个房间存在的人。
It was at that moment that the friend's scheme started changing. The initial plan had been to spend a week in the mall, but the way they saw it, they were sitting on 750 square feet of underutilized space. Then they asked themselves, what would a developer do? Because after all, if you see a space that's underdeveloped, you have a God given responsibility to develop it.
It was at that moment that the friend's scheme started changing. The initial plan had been to spend a week in the mall, but the way they saw it, they were sitting on 750 square feet of underutilized space. Then they asked themselves, what would a developer do? Because after all, if you see a space that's underdeveloped, you have a God given responsibility to develop it.|||就在那一刻，朋友们的计划开始改变了。最初的计划是在商场里待上一周，但在他们看来，他们正坐拥750平方英尺未被充分利用的空间。然后他们问自己：一个开发商会怎么做？因为毕竟，如果你看到一个未充分开发的地区，你就有上帝赋予的责任去开发它。
So we decided that perhaps the absolute best thing we could do is just build a condo. That is always the answer. If you're not sure what to do with the space, just make it a condo. The new plan was no longer to live in the mall for a week. It was now simply to live in the mall for days at a time, using the room as an apartment. And while that may sound like a nightmare to everyone, but a few weird artists from Providence, Michael and his friends got to work on this little project
So we decided that perhaps the absolute best thing we could do is just build a condo. That is always the answer. If you're not sure what to do with the space, just make it a condo. The new plan was no longer to live in the mall for a week. It was now simply to live in the mall for days at a time, using the room as an apartment. And while that may sound like a nightmare to everyone, but a few weird artists from Providence, Michael and his friends got to work on this little project|||所以我们决定，我们能做的最好的事情或许就是建一套公寓。这永远是唯一的答案。如果你不确定拿这个空间怎么办，那就把它改造成公寓。新计划不再是在商场里住上一周。现在，计划变成了每次在商场里住上好几天，把这个房间当成公寓。虽然对所有人来说这听起来像是一场噩梦，除了普罗维登斯的几个怪咖艺术家之外，迈克尔和他的朋友们还是着手开始了这个小项目，
with the excitement of new homeowners. Step one, of course, was cleaning. They had to get rid of all that debris. It's sort of like, you know, like in a prison break movie. We were literally filling up our backpacks with just dirt and grime, and then carrying it out of the mall and getting rid of it. And for every backpack full of debris they took out, they'd bring a pack full of something in.
with the excitement of new homeowners. Step one, of course, was cleaning. They had to get rid of all that debris. It's sort of like, you know, like in a prison break movie. We were literally filling up our backpacks with just dirt and grime, and then carrying it out of the mall and getting rid of it. And for every backpack full of debris they took out, they'd bring a pack full of something in.|||带着新房主的兴奋。第一步当然是打扫卫生。他们必须清理掉所有的残骸。这有点像，你知道的，就像在越狱电影里那样。我们的背包里装满了尘土和污垢，然后把它背出商场扔掉。他们每运出一背包垃圾，就会带回一背包别的东西。
Gallon jugs of water for drinking and cleaning, clamp lights and extension cords for illumination, which they plugged into the mall's internal power system, parts for an ad hoc kitchen. They even built a cinder block wall to hide the space from anyone else who might venture into the cavern complex from its various other entrances. We went and got a door that was an exact mirror of the doors they use in the mall. So if you were to find it, unless you're looking really closely at first glance, it just looks exactly like it had been built originally. Finally, it was time to decorate.
Gallon jugs of water for drinking and cleaning, clamp lights and extension cords for illumination, which they plugged into the mall's internal power system, parts for an ad hoc kitchen. They even built a cinder block wall to hide the space from anyone else who might venture into the cavern complex from its various other entrances. We went and got a door that was an exact mirror of the doors they use in the mall. So if you were to find it, unless you're looking really closely at first glance, it just looks exactly like it had been built originally. Finally, it was time to decorate.|||用于饮用和清洁的加仑桶装水、用于照明的夹式灯和延长线（他们将其插在商场的内部供电系统上）、临时厨房的零件。他们甚至砌了一堵煤渣砖墙，把这个空间藏起来，以防其他人从其他各种入口闯入这个洞穴群。我们去弄来了一扇门，跟商场里使用的门一模一样。所以如果你找到了它，除非你仔细观察，否则乍一看，它看起来就像是原本就建在那里的。最后，到了装修的时候。
Anything we could buy at the mall, we would. A low table came in on top of that, proudly perched with a television and our PlayStation. But if we couldn't buy it at the mall, we'd have to bring it into the mall. And that's for the large pieces like the China Hutch or the fourth piece sectional couch. Nobody looked twice that you brought pieces of a couch through the mall?
Anything we could buy at the mall, we would. A low table came in on top of that, proudly perched with a television and our PlayStation. But if we couldn't buy it at the mall, we'd have to bring it into the mall. And that's for the large pieces like the China Hutch or the fourth piece sectional couch. Nobody looked twice that you brought pieces of a couch through the mall?|||任何能在商场买到的东西，我们都会买。一张矮桌被搬了进来，上面自豪地摆着一台电视和我们的PlayStation。但如果我们在商场买不到，我们就得把它运进商场。对于大件物品，比如中式碗柜或四件套组合沙发，也是如此。没有人对你把沙发部件运进商场多看两眼吗？
How did you get that in there? In broad daylight. We avoided the night and sort of worked with the ebb and flow of the mall. We were just part of the living organism of its daily activities. It may seem risky trying to furnish a secret apartment with a nested coffee table, but to anyone watching, it was just a person walking through a mall with a nested coffee table that they just bought at the mall. There's simply no such thing as a suspicious consumer item in a building that is dedicated
How did you get that in there? In broad daylight. We avoided the night and sort of worked with the ebb and flow of the mall. We were just part of the living organism of its daily activities. It may seem risky trying to furnish a secret apartment with a nested coffee table, but to anyone watching, it was just a person walking through a mall with a nested coffee table that they just bought at the mall. There's simply no such thing as a suspicious consumer item in a building that is dedicated|||你是怎么把它弄进去的？在大白天。我们避开了夜晚，顺应着商场的人流起落。我们只是它日常活动这个生命有机体的一部分。试图用嵌套茶几来布置秘密公寓可能看起来很冒险，但对任何旁观者来说，这只是一个拿着刚刚在商场里买的嵌套茶几走过商场的人。在一栋专门用于消费的建筑里，根本不存在什么可疑的消费品。
to consumerism. The friends would sometimes stay in the secret apartment for several weeks in a row, just living, watching television, making collages with shadow boxes they bought at Pottery Barn, even cooking in the ad hoc kitchen. Michael remembers burning some waffles with a waffle iron and wondering if the smoke would give them away. And when the eight friends weren't enjoying their secret apartment, they were enjoying the mall, not as shoppers, but as residents. Thanks to its late night movie theater, the mall almost never closed.
to consumerism. The friends would sometimes stay in the secret apartment for several weeks in a row, just living, watching television, making collages with shadow boxes they bought at Pottery Barn, even cooking in the ad hoc kitchen. Michael remembers burning some waffles with a waffle iron and wondering if the smoke would give them away. And when the eight friends weren't enjoying their secret apartment, they were enjoying the mall, not as shoppers, but as residents. Thanks to its late night movie theater, the mall almost never closed.|||朋友们有时会连续几个星期呆在秘密公寓里，只是生活、看电视、用在Pottery Barn买的阴影盒制作拼贴画，甚至在临时厨房里做饭。迈克尔记得他用华夫饼机烤糊了一些华夫饼，还在想烟味会不会暴露他们的行踪。当这八个朋友没有在享受他们的秘密公寓时，他们就在享受商场，不是作为购物者，而是作为居民。多亏了深夜电影院，这家商场几乎从不关门。
So sometimes they would just roam the building with no goal in mind, observing its many moods. There are times when that entire building probably had maybe 10 people in it, like in the middle of the night. There'd be security officers, there'd be cleaning staff. And it's a really wonderful time because it's like having a public park four levels deep all to yourself. And in those moments, there's a sense of ownership and I just feel really good.
So sometimes they would just roam the building with no goal in mind, observing its many moods. There are times when that entire building probably had maybe 10 people in it, like in the middle of the night. There'd be security officers, there'd be cleaning staff. And it's a really wonderful time because it's like having a public park four levels deep all to yourself. And in those moments, there's a sense of ownership and I just feel really good.|||所以有时他们会漫无目的地在建筑里闲逛，观察它各种各样的神态。有时候，整栋大楼里可能只有大约10个人，比如在半夜。会有保安人员，会有保洁人员。那真的是一段美妙的时光，因为就像拥有了一个四层楼深的公共公园，而且完全属于你一个人。在那些时刻，有一种所有权的感觉，我感觉真的很好。
Weeks turned to months and eventually years. Out of the emotional rubble of Fort Thunder, they'd finally found their refuge. And all thanks to the mall's developers, who had accidentally provided a sanctuary from the world they were busy developing. But as the old saying goes, there comes a time in every man's life when he must stop living at the mall. Unfortunately, the seed got planted that this whole thing was going to unravel. And that's because we had a break-in.
Weeks turned to months and eventually years. Out of the emotional rubble of Fort Thunder, they'd finally found their refuge. And all thanks to the mall's developers, who had accidentally provided a sanctuary from the world they were busy developing. But as the old saying goes, there comes a time in every man's life when he must stop living at the mall. Unfortunately, the seed got planted that this whole thing was going to unravel. And that's because we had a break-in.|||几周变成了几个月，最终变成了几年。从“雷霆堡”的情感废墟中，他们终于找到了避难所。这一切都要归功于商场的开发商，他们无意中提供了一个庇护所，让人得以逃离他们正忙于开发的世界。但俗话说得好，每个人的一生中总会迎来这样一个时刻：他必须停止住在商场里的生活。不幸的是，事情即将败露的种子已经种下了。那是因为我们遭遇了一次入室盗窃。
One day, they came back to the apartment, only to discover that someone had kicked open the door and stolen the PlayStation, along with several other small items, including the art they had made and a photo album. But they left the silverware, they left the TV, we're like, this is a very odd burglary. Like they didn't take the things of value,
One day, they came back to the apartment, only to discover that someone had kicked open the door and stolen the PlayStation, along with several other small items, including the art they had made and a photo album. But they left the silverware, they left the TV, we're like, this is a very odd burglary. Like they didn't take the things of value,|||有一天，他们回到公寓，却发现有人踢开了门，偷走了PlayStation，以及其他几件小物品，包括他们创作的艺术品和一本相册。但他们留下了银器，留下了电视，我们当时就想：这是一场非常奇怪的盗窃案。因为他们没有拿有价值的东西，
they only took the things that were like super personal. Michael and his friends were spooked. They had managed to hide the apartment for four years, but now someone knew about the room. Someone who could come back at any time and who seemed to be interested in them. So they changed things up. They decided from now on, they'd only stay there at night
they only took the things that were like super personal. Michael and his friends were spooked. They had managed to hide the apartment for four years, but now someone knew about the room. Someone who could come back at any time and who seemed to be interested in them. So they changed things up. They decided from now on, they'd only stay there at night|||他们只拿了那些超级私人的东西。迈克尔和他的朋友们吓坏了。他们设法把公寓隐藏了四年，但现在有人知道了这个房间。一个随时可能回来、而且似乎对他们感兴趣的人。所以他们改变了策略。他们决定从今以后，只在夜间呆在那里，
when the chances of being caught were low, never during the day. And crucially, they would double down on another rule they'd had since almost the very beginning. Don't share it with anyone. Don't physically bring anyone here who wasn't involved in the making of it. So a lot of my very, very good and best friends
when the chances of being caught were low, never during the day. And crucially, they would double down on another rule they'd had since almost the very beginning. Don't share it with anyone. Don't physically bring anyone here who wasn't involved in the making of it. So a lot of my very, very good and best friends|||那时被抓到的几率很低，白天绝对不去。至关重要的是，他们将严格遵守几乎从一开始就有的另一条规定：不要与任何人分享。不要把任何没有参与建造它的人带到这里来。所以我的很多很多好朋友、最好的朋友，
never saw the space. And I'm the one who took that rule and broke it. Michael was hosting a visiting artist from Hong Kong. Her name was Jaffa. He was driving her to the bus station on her way out of town. And we're driving past the mall and I say to myself, what can it hurt? How could this possibly backfire on me? So I brought her into the space. Her mind was absolutely blown.
never saw the space. And I'm the one who took that rule and broke it. Michael was hosting a visiting artist from Hong Kong. Her name was Jaffa. He was driving her to the bus station on her way out of town. And we're driving past the mall and I say to myself, what can it hurt? How could this possibly backfire on me? So I brought her into the space. Her mind was absolutely blown.|||从未见过这个空间。而我偏偏打破了这条规矩。迈克尔当时正在接待一位来自香港的访问艺术家。她叫贾法。他正开车送她去公交车站，她准备离开这个小镇。当我们开车经过商场时，我对自己说：这有什么大不了的？这怎么可能会对我产生反噬呢？于是我把她带进了这个空间。她的脑洞大开，震惊得无以复加。
You got to remember that this is at the peak of its build out. Michael showed Jaffa everything. The couch, the lights, the television. They were just days away from installing a water tank and a wood floor. In spite of the break-in, after four years of work, the apartment was on the verge of feeling like a real home. But when we're leaving, I hear a walkie talkie
You got to remember that this is at the peak of its build out. Michael showed Jaffa everything. The couch, the lights, the television. They were just days away from installing a water tank and a wood floor. In spite of the break-in, after four years of work, the apartment was on the verge of feeling like a real home. But when we're leaving, I hear a walkie talkie|||你得记住，当时这已经处于建设的巅峰期了。迈克尔把一切都展示给贾法看。沙发、灯光、电视。他们再过几天就要安装水箱和木地板了。尽管遭遇了入室盗窃，经过四年的努力，这间公寓眼看着就要有家的感觉了。但当我们离开时，我听到对讲机的声音……
on the other side of the door within two feet of us. And when the door opens, it's three dudes in ties and sports jackets. And I realize in that moment, I internalize that it's over. It turned out that the earlier break-in had been the work of two of the mall's newest security guards. Instead of removing everything, they had taken the personal items in hopes of figuring out who Michael and his friends were. Now that Michael had been foolish enough to come back during the day, they had their man. General Growth Properties, the company that owned the mall, did not take kindly to the
on the other side of the door within two feet of us. And when the door opens, it's three dudes in ties and sports jackets. And I realize in that moment, I internalize that it's over. It turned out that the earlier break-in had been the work of two of the mall's newest security guards. Instead of removing everything, they had taken the personal items in hopes of figuring out who Michael and his friends were. Now that Michael had been foolish enough to come back during the day, they had their man. General Growth Properties, the company that owned the mall, did not take kindly to the|||就在门的那一边，距离我们不到两英尺。当门打开时，是三个系着领带、穿着运动夹克的家伙。那一刻我意识到，我心里明白，一切都结束了。原来，早先的入室盗窃是商场两个新来的保安干的。他们没有清理掉所有东西，而是拿走了私人物品，希望借此弄清迈克尔和他的朋友们是谁。现在，既然迈克尔蠢到在大白天回来，他们可算抓到人了。拥有该商场的“通用成长地产公司”可对……
secret apartment in its walls. You don't say? After being handed over to the police and interrogated, Jaffa was eventually let go. But Michael soon found himself standing in front of a judge in criminal court, charged with breaking and entering and felony trespass. By the time I get to court, the mall has hired a lawyer and they launch into all these details about the illegal things that I have done. And I keep my mouth shut.
secret apartment in its walls. You don't say? After being handed over to the police and interrogated, Jaffa was eventually let go. But Michael soon found himself standing in front of a judge in criminal court, charged with breaking and entering and felony trespass. By the time I get to court, the mall has hired a lawyer and they launch into all these details about the illegal things that I have done. And I keep my mouth shut.|||墙壁里的秘密公寓感到十分恼火。可不是吗？在移交给警方并接受审讯后，贾法最终被释放了。但迈克尔很快发现自己站在刑事法庭的法官面前，被指控私闯民宅和重罪侵入。等我到法庭时，商场已经请了律师，他们开始滔滔不绝地讲述我所做过的种种违法细节。而我则闭口不言。
But after they've gone through this laundry list of illegal activities, they use the phrase, this gave Mr. Townsend access to an apartment that they had built over several years that had the following things in it and goes onto list in detail what the apartment looked like. Including the coffee table, the television, a copy of the game Grand Theft Auto,
But after they've gone through this laundry list of illegal activities, they use the phrase, this gave Mr. Townsend access to an apartment that they had built over several years that had the following things in it and goes onto list in detail what the apartment looked like. Including the coffee table, the television, a copy of the game Grand Theft Auto,|||但在他们列举完这一长串非法活动之后，他们用了这样一句话：“这让汤森先生得以进入他们历时数年建造的一间公寓，里面有以下物品”，接着便开始详细列举公寓的模样。包括茶几、电视、《侠盗猎车手》游戏光盘、
an eight foot China hutch, a four piece sectional couch, silverware for eight with matching glassware, a six foot pot. And the more details this lawyer gives, the more the judge just looks around. And he's like, what's happening here? The judge hustles advisors close to him, and I hear him whispering. And then he looks up, looks me dead in the eyes, and he goes,
an eight foot China hutch, a four piece sectional couch, silverware for eight with matching glassware, a six foot pot. And the more details this lawyer gives, the more the judge just looks around. And he's like, what's happening here? The judge hustles advisors close to him, and I hear him whispering. And then he looks up, looks me dead in the eyes, and he goes,|||一个八英尺的中式碗柜、一套四件套组合沙发、八人份配有配套玻璃器皿的银器、一个六英尺的花盆。这位律师给出的细节越多，法官就越是四处张望。他好像在说：这到底是怎么回事？法官把顾问拉到自己身边，我听到他在低声耳语。然后他抬起头，直勾勾地盯着我的眼睛，说道：
this is not a criminal act. We're not sure exactly what it was, but this is not a crime. Whether the judge was perceiving a deep legal truth at the heart of this case, or Michael was just the beneficiary of an incredible amount of white privilege, Michael may never know. In the end, he was slapped with a misdemeanor for trespassing and released. He had lived on and off in the secret apartment for nearly four years,
this is not a criminal act. We're not sure exactly what it was, but this is not a crime. Whether the judge was perceiving a deep legal truth at the heart of this case, or Michael was just the beneficiary of an incredible amount of white privilege, Michael may never know. In the end, he was slapped with a misdemeanor for trespassing and released. He had lived on and off in the secret apartment for nearly four years,|||这不是犯罪行为。我们不确定这到底算什么，但这绝对不是犯罪。这位法官是参透了本案核心深处的深奥法律真理，还是迈克尔只是享有惊人白人特权的受益者，迈克尔可能永远不会知道了。最终，他因非法侵入被判犯有轻罪并被释放。断断续续地，他在秘密公寓里住了将近四年，
and it was going to cost him almost nothing. But that doesn't mean he got away entirely scot-free. Just before Michael left the mall, the mall security team handed him a piece of paper, the same piece of paper they hand to brawlers, shoplifters, and anyone else who has overstayed their welcome in this most private of public spaces. This is standardized manila piece of paper which has a map of the mall.
and it was going to cost him almost nothing. But that doesn't mean he got away entirely scot-free. Just before Michael left the mall, the mall security team handed him a piece of paper, the same piece of paper they hand to brawlers, shoplifters, and anyone else who has overstayed their welcome in this most private of public spaces. This is standardized manila piece of paper which has a map of the mall.|||而且几乎没花他什么钱。但这并不意味着他完全毫发无伤地脱身了。就在迈克尔离开商场前，商场保安团队递给他一张纸——就是他们递给打架斗殴者、小偷以及任何在这个极具私密性的公共空间里滞留过久的人的那种纸。这是一张印有商场地图的标准化牛皮纸。
It has this red line around the whole thing. You have to sign it and it says you can't cross that red line. So to make it clear you're never coming back. Now, over a decade later, Michael still lives right near the mall. But his days of running anywhere near its 13 acres are over. And the biggest bummer for me is that if I want to go to downtown, the path that you bring your bike through
It has this red line around the whole thing. You have to sign it and it says you can't cross that red line. So to make it clear you're never coming back. Now, over a decade later, Michael still lives right near the mall. But his days of running anywhere near its 13 acres are over. And the biggest bummer for me is that if I want to go to downtown, the path that you bring your bike through|||整张地图周围画着一条红线。你必须在上面签字，上面写着你不能跨越那条红线。以此明确表示你再也不会回来了。如今，十多年过去了，迈克尔依然住在商场附近。但他再也不能在那13英亩的土地附近跑步了。对我来说最糟糕的是，如果我想去市中心，你推着自行车通过的小路……
is through the center of the malt where it bridges over the river And now that I'm banned from the mall. I have to bike around it And I and I've biked around it for 10 years Diligently I've I have never broken this rule. So you really can never go back. I could never go back go back. I could never go back. Since we heard that story, Michael did honor the ban, up until very recently. At the climax of the new documentary, he sneaks back in to see what's left of the apartment, but all he finds is a door and a couple of cinder blocks. Meanwhile, things are not going well for the mall. By the fall of 2024, its management company had fallen behind on their $259 million of debt and a judge ordered the mall into receivership.
is through the center of the malt where it bridges over the river And now that I'm banned from the mall. I have to bike around it And I and I've biked around it for 10 years Diligently I've I have never broken this rule. So you really can never go back. I could never go back go back. I could never go back. Since we heard that story, Michael did honor the ban, up until very recently. At the climax of the new documentary, he sneaks back in to see what's left of the apartment, but all he finds is a door and a couple of cinder blocks. Meanwhile, things are not going well for the mall. By the fall of 2024, its management company had fallen behind on their $259 million of debt and a judge ordered the mall into receivership.|||是穿过横跨河流的商场中心。既然我被禁止进入商场，我就得骑车绕行。而且我——我绕着它骑了10年车。我一直勤勤恳恳地遵守规定，从未打破过这条规矩。所以你真的再也回不去了。我再也回不去了，回不去了。我再也回不去了。自从我们听到这个故事以来，迈克尔一直遵守着禁令，直到最近。在新纪录片的高潮部分，他偷偷溜回去查看公寓还剩下什么，但他发现的只是一扇门和几块煤渣砖。与此同时，商场的情况并不妙。到2024年秋天，其管理公司已经拖欠了2.59亿美元的债务，法官下令将商场置于接管状态。
Attorneys John Dorsey and Mark Russo were appointed to turn around the mall's finances and lure shoppers back. As part of their publicity push, they have effectively granted Townsend a pardon. They commissioned him to install art pieces and empty storefronts, and the mall's movie theater hosted a premiere of the documentary. Dorsey even went into the mall's catacombs for a photo-op where the apartment had been. And one of the ideas that Dorsey and Russo have floated to save the mall is converting some parts of it into residential apartments. Legal, non-secret apartments. That episode was reported by Vanessa Lowe, edited by Joe Rosenberg, tech production by
Attorneys John Dorsey and Mark Russo were appointed to turn around the mall's finances and lure shoppers back. As part of their publicity push, they have effectively granted Townsend a pardon. They commissioned him to install art pieces and empty storefronts, and the mall's movie theater hosted a premiere of the documentary. Dorsey even went into the mall's catacombs for a photo-op where the apartment had been. And one of the ideas that Dorsey and Russo have floated to save the mall is converting some parts of it into residential apartments. Legal, non-secret apartments. That episode was reported by Vanessa Lowe, edited by Joe Rosenberg, tech production by|||律师约翰·多尔西和马克·鲁索被任命来扭转商场的财务状况并吸引购物者重返商场。作为宣传造势的一部分，他们实际上给予了汤森特赦。他们委托他在空置的店面里装置艺术品，商场的电影院还举办了该纪录片的首映式。多尔西甚至深入商场的地下墓穴（曾经的公寓所在地）进行拍照作秀。多尔西和鲁索提出的拯救商场的想法之一，是将商场的部分区域改造成住宅公寓。合法的、非秘密的公寓。本期节目由凡妮莎·洛报道，乔·罗森伯格剪辑，技术制作由……
Sharif Youssef, a different version originally aired on the podcast Nocturne. Secret Mall Apartment is playing now in select cities. Michael and his friends filmed almost everything they did at the time, and the footage is delightful to watch. We'll have a link in the show notes. After the break, where did malls come from, and where are they going? In the credits of the Secret Mall Apartment documentary, there's one name in the special thanks section that will jump out at you if you're a long time 99PI listener, and that's
Sharif Youssef, a different version originally aired on the podcast Nocturne. Secret Mall Apartment is playing now in select cities. Michael and his friends filmed almost everything they did at the time, and the footage is delightful to watch. We'll have a link in the show notes. After the break, where did malls come from, and where are they going? In the credits of the Secret Mall Apartment documentary, there's one name in the special thanks section that will jump out at you if you're a long time 99PI listener, and that's|||谢里夫·优素福负责。另一个版本最初在播客《夜曲》中播出。《商场里的秘密公寓》目前正在部分城市上映。迈克尔和他的朋友们当时几乎拍下了他们做过的一切，这些影像看起来非常有趣。我们将在节目介绍中提供链接。休息过后，商场从何而来，又将走向何方？在纪录片《商场里的秘密公寓》的演职员表里，特别鸣谢部分有一个名字，如果你是99PI的长期听众，它一定会跳入你的眼帘，那就是……
the name Alexandra Lang. We've had her on the show as an expert eight times, which I think might be a record. Anyway, back in 2022, she came on the show to tell us about the rise and fall of the mall, how the COVID-19 pandemic accelerated the shift towards online shopping, and what we should do with all that empty space. Like many teens in the 80s, my first job was at the mall. I was 14. I lied about my age.
the name Alexandra Lang. We've had her on the show as an expert eight times, which I think might be a record. Anyway, back in 2022, she came on the show to tell us about the rise and fall of the mall, how the COVID-19 pandemic accelerated the shift towards online shopping, and what we should do with all that empty space. Like many teens in the 80s, my first job was at the mall. I was 14. I lied about my age.|||亚历山德拉·朗这个名字。她作为专家上过我们的节目八次，我想这可能是一个纪录。不管怎样，早在2022年，她就来到节目中，给我们讲述了商场的兴衰、新冠疫情如何加速向网络购物的转变，以及我们应该如何处理所有这些空置空间。就像80年代的许多青少年一样，我的第一份工作也是在商场。我当时14岁。我谎报了年龄。
I was a busboy in an Applebee-style restaurant that no longer exists. On Saturdays, I often worked three shifts in a row, so I witnessed the entire circadian rhythm of the mall. At eight o'clock, I'd clean windows as the senior citizens in tracksuits powered through the empty halls, passing by shops with the cage doors still rolled down.
I was a busboy in an Applebee-style restaurant that no longer exists. On Saturdays, I often worked three shifts in a row, so I witnessed the entire circadian rhythm of the mall. At eight o'clock, I'd clean windows as the senior citizens in tracksuits powered through the empty halls, passing by shops with the cage doors still rolled down.|||我在一家已经不复存在的苹果蜂风格餐厅当服务生。星期六我经常连续上三个班，所以我目睹了商场完整的昼夜节律。八点钟，当穿着运动服的老年人们快步穿过空旷的大厅、走过铁栅栏门还没拉下来的店铺时，我正在擦窗户。
By midday, the families took over, and my usual job of cleaning glasses and plates involved cleaning up piles of food spilled on the floor. By evening, the teens arrived. They couldn't afford the restaurant, but I could see them in packs, congregating by the fountain, always ready, with an unkind word or some act of cruelty. The mall felt terrible. I hated it. But despite this, on days when I wasn't working, I had my mom drop me off at the mall.
By midday, the families took over, and my usual job of cleaning glasses and plates involved cleaning up piles of food spilled on the floor. By evening, the teens arrived. They couldn't afford the restaurant, but I could see them in packs, congregating by the fountain, always ready, with an unkind word or some act of cruelty. The mall felt terrible. I hated it. But despite this, on days when I wasn't working, I had my mom drop me off at the mall.|||到了中午，家庭成了主角，我平常清理杯子和盘子的工作还包括清理洒在地上的成堆食物。到了傍晚，青少年们来了。他们消费不起这家餐厅，但我能看到他们三五成群地聚集在喷泉旁，随时准备说一句刻薄的话或做出某种残忍的举动。商场感觉糟透了。我讨厌它。但尽管如此，在我休息的日子里，我还是让我妈把我送到商场。
Kids in small towns and suburbs play the hand they're dealt and being able to walk around on your own, maybe buying a cassette tape of the Smith's live album at Sam Goody, is the best that life has to offer. I was not a very cool teen. Let me just say, I was a very nerdy teen. This is cool adult in front of the show, Alexander Lang. I feel like there are a lot of teenage mall scenarios that I did not participate in. Like I did not like meet my first bow at the mall.
Kids in small towns and suburbs play the hand they're dealt and being able to walk around on your own, maybe buying a cassette tape of the Smith's live album at Sam Goody, is the best that life has to offer. I was not a very cool teen. Let me just say, I was a very nerdy teen. This is cool adult in front of the show, Alexander Lang. I feel like there are a lot of teenage mall scenarios that I did not participate in. Like I did not like meet my first bow at the mall.|||小镇和郊区的孩子们只能接受命运发给他们的牌，能够自己到处走走，也许在山姆·古迪唱片店买一盒史密斯乐队现场专辑的磁带，就是生活所能提供的最好的东西了。我曾经不是一个很酷的青少年。我得直说，我曾经是一个书呆子气十足的青少年。坐在节目面前的是酷炫的成年人亚历山德拉·朗。我觉得有很多青少年的商场场景我都没有参与过。比如我没有在商场里遇到我的初恋。
I did not like stroll around with shopping bags showing off at the mall. None of that. But no teen in the 80s could completely avoid the gravitational pull of the mall. Alexandra is the author of a new book called Meet Me By The Fountain. I think part of the whole argument of this book
I did not like stroll around with shopping bags showing off at the mall. None of that. But no teen in the 80s could completely avoid the gravitational pull of the mall. Alexandra is the author of a new book called Meet Me By The Fountain. I think part of the whole argument of this book|||我没有提着购物袋在商场里闲逛显摆过。什么都没有。但在80年代，没有哪个青少年能完全避开商场的引力。亚历山德拉是一本名为《在喷泉旁见》的新书的作者。我认为这本书的整体论点的一部分……
is really that people are social creatures and that the mall had to be created because the suburbs didn't really initially think about a space for people to come together. Even though we're past the heyday of the mall, Alexandra says we haven't seen the death of the mall, even after two and a half years of a global pandemic. I think that people are people and they're going to want to like go back out and get together again. I think we've seen that in like the tremendous use of parks during the pandemic.
is really that people are social creatures and that the mall had to be created because the suburbs didn't really initially think about a space for people to come together. Even though we're past the heyday of the mall, Alexandra says we haven't seen the death of the mall, even after two and a half years of a global pandemic. I think that people are people and they're going to want to like go back out and get together again. I think we've seen that in like the tremendous use of parks during the pandemic.|||其实是人们是社会性动物，商场的诞生是因为郊区最初并没有真正考虑到为人们提供一个聚集的空间。尽管我们已经度过了商场的全盛时期，但亚历山德拉表示，即使经历了两年半的全球大流行，我们也没有看到商场的消亡。我认为人毕竟是人，他们会想要重新走出去聚在一起。我想我们在疫情期间公园的巨大使用率中看到了这一点。
And when we can safely gather indoors, like people are going to be excited to do that because who wants to go to a park in December? We're gonna talk about how the mall became a ubiquitous part of American culture and what's happening today as malls across the country start to disappear. Okay, so let's get down to some basics. What is a mall?
And when we can safely gather indoors, like people are going to be excited to do that because who wants to go to a park in December? We're gonna talk about how the mall became a ubiquitous part of American culture and what's happening today as malls across the country start to disappear. Okay, so let's get down to some basics. What is a mall?|||当我们可以安全地在室内聚集时，人们会为此感到兴奋，因为谁想在12月份去公园呢？我们要讨论的是商场是如何成为美国文化无处不在的一部分的，以及今天随着全国各地的商场开始消失，正在发生着什么。好了，让我们来了解一些基础知识。什么是商场？
What makes something a mall versus other shopping centers that existed before or after? Well, a shopping center is outdoors and a mall is indoors. That's the most basic thing. A shopping center is a strip mall or a line of stores facing the parking lot with some sort of covering over the space in front of them. Whereas a mall is indoors. And the earliest malls were basically just like two shopping strips put together. So you had a department store at each end
What makes something a mall versus other shopping centers that existed before or after? Well, a shopping center is outdoors and a mall is indoors. That's the most basic thing. A shopping center is a strip mall or a line of stores facing the parking lot with some sort of covering over the space in front of them. Whereas a mall is indoors. And the earliest malls were basically just like two shopping strips put together. So you had a department store at each end|||是什么让某个东西成为商场，而不是之前或之后存在的其他购物中心呢？嗯，购物中心是露天的，而商场是内室的。这是最基本的一点。购物中心是条形商业街，或者是一排面对停车场的商店，其前方空间上方有某种遮盖物。而商场是在室内的。最早的商场基本上就像是把两条购物街拼在了一起。所以你会在两端各有一家百货公司……
and then two lines of shops facing each other and a covered central aisle that usually had fountains and plants and benches and other amenities. So they were really just that super simple kind of eye-shaped plan. And this shape, the long hallway, is where the word mall comes from. That's right, yeah.
and then two lines of shops facing each other and a covered central aisle that usually had fountains and plants and benches and other amenities. So they were really just that super simple kind of eye-shaped plan. And this shape, the long hallway, is where the word mall comes from. That's right, yeah.|||然后是两排相对的商店和一个带顶棚的中央过道，通常有喷泉、植物、长椅和其他便利设施。所以它们实际上只是那种超级简单的“工”字形平面规划。而这种形状——长长的走廊，正是“mall”（商场）这个词的来源。没错，是的。
Basically, the name mall comes from Paul Mall in London, which is a narrow street where they used to play a kind of bowling game. So it was this long, narrow outdoor space where people would come together to play. And so the mall from Paul Mall turned into a landscape term for that kind of long, narrow green space. So then when you enclose that long, narrow space under a roof, it is another kind of mall. So the mall in Washington is also a mall from the same origin, even though we don't really think about a shopping mall and the mall in Washington
Basically, the name mall comes from Paul Mall in London, which is a narrow street where they used to play a kind of bowling game. So it was this long, narrow outdoor space where people would come together to play. And so the mall from Paul Mall turned into a landscape term for that kind of long, narrow green space. So then when you enclose that long, narrow space under a roof, it is another kind of mall. So the mall in Washington is also a mall from the same origin, even though we don't really think about a shopping mall and the mall in Washington|||基本上，“mall”这个词源于伦敦的保罗商城（Pall Mall），那是一条狭窄的街道，人们过去常在那里玩一种地滚球游戏。所以这是一个狭长的户外空间，人们会聚在那里玩耍。因此，来自保罗商场的“mall”演变成了一个景观术语，指代那种狭长的绿地。所以，当你把这个狭长的空间用屋顶封闭起来时，它就成了另一种商场。因此，华盛顿的林荫大道（National Mall）也是同源的商场，尽管我们并没有把购物中心和华盛顿的林荫大道……
in the same mental place. That place with the reflecting pool and the Lincoln on one side, that's the Capitol Mall. Right. Lincoln is the anchor store of the National Mall. He's the Macy's of the Capitol Mall. So Victor Gruen is credited as the father of the mall. What was he trying to do? What was he trying to make?
in the same mental place. That place with the reflecting pool and the Lincoln on one side, that's the Capitol Mall. Right. Lincoln is the anchor store of the National Mall. He's the Macy's of the Capitol Mall. So Victor Gruen is credited as the father of the mall. What was he trying to do? What was he trying to make?|||归为同一个心理概念。那个有倒影池、一边是林肯纪念堂的地方，就是国会山林荫大道。没错。林肯是国家林荫大道的主力店。他是国会山林荫大道的梅西百货。因此，维克托·格伦被誉为商场之父。他当时想做什么？他想创造什么？
So Gruen was an emigre from Austria, fled the Nazis to the US in the late 1930s. And he had really strong memories of the kind of charming streets of Vienna, where there are cafes and people gather at fountains and there's this whole rich outdoor life. So he came to America, he initially designed these very glamorous stores in Manhattan, and then he was taken up by some department store executives who were like, move to California, design our department stores. So he started designing these freestanding department stores
So Gruen was an emigre from Austria, fled the Nazis to the US in the late 1930s. And he had really strong memories of the kind of charming streets of Vienna, where there are cafes and people gather at fountains and there's this whole rich outdoor life. So he came to America, he initially designed these very glamorous stores in Manhattan, and then he was taken up by some department store executives who were like, move to California, design our department stores. So he started designing these freestanding department stores|||格伦是一位来自奥地利的移民，在20世纪30年代末为逃避纳粹逃往美国。他对维也纳迷人的街道有着非常深刻的记忆，那里有咖啡馆，人们聚集在喷泉旁，有着丰富多彩的户外生活。于是他来到美国，最初在曼哈顿设计了这些非常迷人的商店，后来被一些百货公司高管看中，他们说：搬到加利福尼亚去，为我们设计百货公司。于是他开始设计这些独立的百货公司……
and he just felt kind of crushed by the landscape around those department stores. Because you could go to the store and you could park and you could go in, but then you couldn't do anything else. Like you couldn't leave and sit at a cafe, there was nowhere to meet your friends. There was none of the kind of fabric of the city
and he just felt kind of crushed by the landscape around those department stores. Because you could go to the store and you could park and you could go in, but then you couldn't do anything else. Like you couldn't leave and sit at a cafe, there was nowhere to meet your friends. There was none of the kind of fabric of the city|||他只是觉得那些百货公司周围的景观让他感到压抑。因为你可以去商店，可以停车，可以进去，但除此之外你什么也做不了。比如你不能离开去咖啡馆坐坐，没有地方和朋友见面。完全没有那种……
that he found in European cities. So in the early 1940s, Gruin was living in New York and flying back and forth across the country a lot, like major, major airplane miles. And he gets stuck in Detroit on a cross-country flight because of fog. And he thinks, oh, okay, like, I'm not going to waste this time I have on the ground in Detroit. You know, it's like he asked his friends, where is life happening in Detroit?
that he found in European cities. So in the early 1940s, Gruin was living in New York and flying back and forth across the country a lot, like major, major airplane miles. And he gets stuck in Detroit on a cross-country flight because of fog. And he thinks, oh, okay, like, I'm not going to waste this time I have on the ground in Detroit. You know, it's like he asked his friends, where is life happening in Detroit?|||他在欧洲城市里找到的城市脉络。因此，在20世纪40年代初，格伦住在纽约，经常坐飞机在全国各地飞来飞去，积累了大量、大量的飞行里程。有一次横跨大陆的飞行中，他在底特律因为大雾被困住了。他想：哦，好吧，我可不能浪费我在底特律地面的时间。你知道的，就像他问他的朋友们：底特律的生活都在哪里发生？
And they said, oh, it's all out in the suburbs. Okay. Where is life happening in Detroit? And they said, oh, it's all out in the suburbs. So he gets driven around the suburbs and he finds what he's been finding elsewhere in the US, that yes, there are all these new houses and yes, there are all these strip malls, but there's nowhere to go. And he thinks that he, you know, master salesman,
And they said, oh, it's all out in the suburbs. Okay. Where is life happening in Detroit? And they said, oh, it's all out in the suburbs. So he gets driven around the suburbs and he finds what he's been finding elsewhere in the US, that yes, there are all these new houses and yes, there are all these strip malls, but there's nowhere to go. And he thinks that he, you know, master salesman,|||他们回答说：哦，全在郊区。好吧。底特律的生活都在哪里发生？他们说：哦，全在郊区。于是他坐车在郊区转悠，发现了他在美国其他地方发现的情况：是的，这里有所有这些新房子，是的，这里有所有这些条形商业街，但就是无处可去。他认为他自己——你知道的，作为一名销售大师——
he should be able to sell J.L. Hudson on the idea of building a branched apartment store and a shopping center in the suburbs. And over the next several years, he does this, he actually sells them on the idea of building four of them, Northland, Southland, Eastland, and Westland. Yeah, I've always wondered about that. Like, why do so many malls have cardinal directions in the name? No matter what city you're in, they're all Westfield or Southport. Why is that?
should be able to sell J.L. Hudson on the idea of building a branched apartment store and a shopping center in the and over the next several years, he does this, he actually sells them on the idea of building four of them, Northland, Southland, Eastland, and Westland. Yeah, I've always wondered about that. Like, why do so many malls have cardinal directions in the name? No matter what city you're in, they're all Westfield or Southport. Why is that?|||应该能够说服J.L.哈德逊公司采纳这样的想法：在郊区建造一家分店式的百货公司和一个购物中心。在接下来的几年里，他确实这么做了，他成功说服他们建造了其中的四个：诺斯兰、索斯兰、伊斯兰和韦斯特兰。是的，我一直很好奇这一点。比如，为什么那么多商场的名字里都有方位词？不管你在哪个城市，它们都是韦斯特菲尔德或绍斯波特。这是为什么呢？
This is the origin story, and this is one way in which I know the book can be slightly confusing because all the malls sound the same and it's like, yeah, that was on purpose. Because if you're thinking about your city with the center point downtown, all of these malls wanted to establish where they were in relation to that center point. So if you were driving north on the main highway out of town, you would encounter Northland or North Park or Northfield or Northdale or one of these other things. Same with South, East or West. So all of them are named after the cardinal points so that people know kind of where to
This is the origin story, and this is one way in which I know the book can be slightly confusing because all the malls sound the same and it's like, yeah, that was on purpose. Because if you're thinking about your city with the center point downtown, all of these malls wanted to establish where they were in relation to that center point. So if you were driving north on the main highway out of town, you would encounter Northland or North Park or Northfield or Northdale or one of these other things. Same with South, East or West. So all of them are named after the cardinal points so that people know kind of where to|||这就是起源故事，这也是这本书可能会让人有点困惑的一个地方，因为所有的商场听起来都一样，感觉就像是：是的，那是故意的。因为如果你把市中心作为中心点来思考你的城市，所有这些商场都想确立它们相对于这个中心点的位置。所以，如果你沿着出城的主干道向北开车，你会遇到诺斯兰、诺斯帕克、诺斯菲尔德、诺斯代尔或诸如此类的东西。南、东、西也是如此。所以它们都以方位词命名，以便人们知道大概在哪里可以……
find them in relation to downtown. And then the second part of the word is gate because it's an entry to the city, it's land because that was open land before, it's park because they're attaching it to a parkway. They have vague geographical associations. The problem really comes that I grew up going to North Gate Mall in Durham, North Carolina, but there's a much more famous North Gate Mall in Seattle, that was one of the first malls.
find them in relation to downtown. And then the second part of the word is gate because it's an entry to the city, it's land because that was open land before, it's park because they're attaching it to a parkway. They have vague geographical associations. The problem really comes that I grew up going to North Gate Mall in Durham, North Carolina, but there's a much more famous North Gate Mall in Seattle, that was one of the first malls.|||根据它们与市中心的关系找到它们。名字的第二部分是“门”（gate），因为它是通往城市的入口；是“地”（land），因为这里以前是开阔的土地；是“公园”（park），因为它们将其连接到公园大道。它们有着模糊的地理联系。真正的问题在于，我是在北卡罗来纳州达勒姆的北门购物中心长大的，但在西雅图有一个更著名的北门购物中心，那是最早的商场之一。
And it's like, so you always have to specify, you know, which city you're talking about. Yeah. And it feels like there's a certain point where the naming convention becomes just a meaningless convention. Like, I, the, the, one of the fancier malls in downtown San Francisco is called Westfield.
And it's like, so you always have to specify, you know, which city you're talking about. Yeah. And it feels like there's a certain point where the naming convention becomes just a meaningless convention. Like, I, the, the, one of the fancier malls in downtown San Francisco is called Westfield.|||所以就像是，你总是得具体说明，你知道的，你到底在说哪个城市。是的。感觉在某个特定时间点，这种命名习俗变成了一种毫无意义的惯例。比如，我——旧金山市中心最高档的商场之一叫韦斯特菲尔德。
I don't think it's west of anything or a field at all. But maybe that's just, I don't know, maybe you know. No, no, Westfield is actually a huge mall conglomerate that's now owned by Australians. Yeah. But Westfield may be originally named after a Westfield that was in some town. So Gruen designed these malls in Michigan,
I don't think it's west of anything or a field at all. But maybe that's just, I don't know, maybe you know. No, no, Westfield is actually a huge mall conglomerate that's now owned by Australians. Yeah. But Westfield may be originally named after a Westfield that was in some town. So Gruen designed these malls in Michigan,|||我觉得它既不位于什么的西边，也根本不是什么田野。但也许这只是——我不知道，也许你知道。不，不，韦斯特菲尔德实际上是一个巨大的商场财团，现在由澳大利亚人拥有。是的。但韦斯特菲尔德最初可能是以某个城镇的一个韦斯特菲尔德命名的。所以格伦在密歇根设计了这些商场，
and he saw the early mall as more of a mixed-use hub. There were shops and department stores, but also post offices and doctor's offices. How long did that idea of a mall last? Yeah, Gruen definitely saw the malls as having a community function, and that's really explicit in a lot of his writings in the malls as having a community function, and that's really explicit in a lot of his writings in the 1940s and 1950s.
and he saw the early mall as more of a mixed-use hub. There were shops and department stores, but also post offices and doctor's offices. How long did that idea of a mall last? Yeah, Gruen definitely saw the malls as having a community function, and that's really explicit in a lot of his writings in the malls as having a community function, and that's really explicit in a lot of his writings in the|||他将早期的商场视为一个更多功能的混合用途枢纽。这里有商店和百货公司，但也有邮局和诊所。这种商场的理念持续了多久？是的，格伦绝对认为商场具有社区功能，这在他20世纪40年代和50年代的许多著作中都有非常明确的体现。
And he wasn't alone in that. There are other early mall developers, including James Rouse, who comes back into the story later, who also built malls circa 1955, 1956, that had community spaces. They might have church spaces, they definitely had doctor's offices, a lot of malls also had nurseries. So these early malls had a lot more community functions built in and they were thought of as replacing downtown.
1940s and 1950s. And he wasn't alone in that. There are other early mall developers, including James Rouse, who comes back into the story later, who also built malls circa 1955, 1956, that had community spaces. They might have church spaces, they definitely had doctor's offices, a lot of malls also had nurseries. So these early malls had a lot more community functions built in and they were thought of as replacing downtown.|||而且他并不孤单。还有其他早期的商场开发商，包括詹姆斯·鲁斯（他后来又回到了这个故事中），他在1955年、1956年前后也建造了带有社区空间的商场。它们可能有教堂空间，绝对有诊所，许多商场还有托儿所。因此，这些早期的商场内置了更多的社区功能，并且被认为是市中心的替代品。
And so having these mixed use functions. But what happened was over time, like by the mid mid-1960s, there just start to be more and more malls, and they're not being designed and created by these original developers, and the developers just want to make money. And they've also found that, you know, the mall has been kind of incorporated as an American pastime, and it turns out you don't need to have a community space for your mall to operate like a community center. Like it's just doing that anyway.
所以，这种混合用途的功能就这样诞生了。但随之发生的是，随着时间推移，到了20世纪60年代中期，购物中心开始如雨春笋般涌现，它们不再由最初的开发商设计建造，而开发商只想赚钱。他们还发现，你知道，购物中心已经融入了美国人的消遣方式，结果证明，要让购物中心像社区中心一样运作，你根本不需要什么社区空间。它反正都在发挥这种作用。
So the mall is often blamed for killing downtowns, but is this completely fair? Was the mall a reaction to filling a void that was already created by downtowns in decline, or did they contribute in some way? The early malls were really predicated on investment by the department stores, but the department store owners only made that investment after they were already seeing a loss of business The early malls were really predicated on investment by the department stores, but the department store owners only made that investment after they were already seeing a loss of business downtown. And the families who owned these department stores were frequently major urban philanthropists.
因此，人们经常将市中心衰落归咎于购物中心，但这完全公正吗？购物中心是对市中心本已形成的空白的一种填补反应，还是它们在某种程度上起到了推波助澜的作用？早期的购物中心实际上是以百货公司的投资为基础的，但百货公司老板只有在看到业务已经出现下滑时才会进行这种投资。早期的购物中心实际上是以百货公司的投资为基础的，但百货公司老板只有在看到业务已经出现下滑时才会进行这种投资。而拥有这些百货公司的家族往往是主要的城市慈善家。
They were the ones who paid for new shows at the museum. They were really power players in Minneapolis, Detroit, Philadelphia, and these other cities. But as the suburbs expanded because the houses were built first, they began to draw all of this energy away from downtowns. And initially, and now it seems foolishly in retrospect, people thought that women would drive back into downtowns to shop during the day, either drive or take public transportation. But once women and children were kind of ensconced in their houses in the suburbs, that was just
他们是出资赞助博物馆新展览的人。他们确实是明尼阿波利斯、底特律、费城和其他这些城市里的权势人物。但随着郊区不断扩张——因为房子是先建好的，它们开始把市中心的所有活力都吸引走。起初，现在回想起来似乎很愚蠢，人们以为女性白天会开车或坐公共交通回到市中心购物。但一旦妇女和儿童在郊区的家中安顿下来，那就简直
impossible. Like who would want to do that? And the shopping options were really limited because they were mostly these strip malls that had a supermarket and a drug store and maybe a kid's shoe store. But they didn't have the kind of full service department store that they did downtown. So department store owners really wanted people to keep going downtown,
不可能了。谁会想那样做呢？而且购物选择其实很有限，因为大多是那种带有一家超市、一家药店，可能还有一家童鞋店的步行街购物广场。但它们没有市中心那种全方位服务的百货公司。所以百货公司老板真的很希望人们继续去市中心，
because that's where they had put all of this time in investment. That was not an accurate read on human behavior. So very reluctantly, department store owners began first to build some small, freestanding stores. behavior. So very reluctantly, department store owners began first to build some small freestanding stores, they called them, you know, like junior stores. And then Gruen kind of came up with this way by packaging the department store
因为那是他们投入了大量时间和投资的地方。对人类行为的这种解读并不准确。因此，百货公司老板非常勉强地开始首先建造一些小型、独立的商店。行为。所以，百货公司老板非常勉强地开始首先建造一些小型独立的商店，他们管它们叫，你知道的，类似于初级商店。然后格鲁恩想出了一种方法，把百货公司
with other stores that they could keep like their sense of dignity. Like they really wanted their stores to still be glamorous and still be special and not just another thing by the highway. So the Gruen idea of the indoor shopping mall allowed them to keep some of that glamour from downtown and also feed off other shopping, but move out to the suburbs. So these early malls go up and they get a lot of attention, especially this one large mall designed by Victor Gruen in Adina, Minnesota, called Southdale Center. And it's a big media story. But how are
与其他商店打包在一起，这样它们就能保持某种尊严感。因为他们真的很希望自己的商店依然光鲜亮丽、与众不同，而不仅仅是公路边的又一个普通店铺。因此，格鲁恩关于室内购物中心的构想让他们得以保留市中心的那一部分魅力，同时借助其他商店的人气，但又搬到了郊区。于是这些早期的购物中心拔地而起，并备受瞩目，尤其是这座由维克托·格鲁恩在明尼苏达州埃迪纳设计的名为“绍思代尔中心”的大型购物中心。它成了一个轰动的大新闻。但是，
these early malls received by the architecture and design world at large? Like, how did they respond? The architecture press was totally wowed by the early malls. You know, Southdale in particular was treated as this kind of second coming. One of the amazing things is that Jane Jacobs went out to Edina to see Southdale and wrote this like very glowing write-up of it in Architectural Forum.
整个建筑和设计界是如何看待这些早期购物中心的？他们的反应如何？建筑界媒体对早期的购物中心赞不绝口。你知道，绍思代尔尤其被当作某种二次降临来对待。最神奇的事情之一就是，简·雅各布斯曾专门去埃迪纳参观绍思代尔，并在《建筑论坛》上写了一篇非常赞赏的报道。
And if you think about our stereotype of Jane Jacobs, she was all about the city, she was all about like small business. But at that moment, it was really seen as an important new element or important new tool for creating, you know, urbanism in the suburbs. The outside of shopping malls is really boring. They're just like these big gray boxes when you see them from the road. But all the design thinking goes into the inside of the mall with things like fountains and atriums. Why is that? I think that's where the community idea, this kind of utopian community idea from the Gruin
如果你回想我们对简·雅各布斯固有印象，她全心关注城市，全心关注小商业。但在那个时刻，它确实被视为在郊区创造城市主义的一种重要新元素或重要新工具。购物中心的外观其实非常无聊。从路上看过去，它们就像是一个个巨大的灰色盒子。但所有的设计心思都花在了购物中心的内部，比如喷泉和中庭。这是为什么呢？我想，这正是社区理念的延续，这种来自格鲁恩
inception of the mall really continues. Because if you're in a space that just makes you want to shuffle along, like say an airport terminal, you don't want to stay there. But if you're in a space where there's beautiful natural light and maybe there's a fountain that your kids can throw pennies into, or maybe there's a bench so you can like take a little break in between going from store to store, you're gonna stay there longer. And so even if mall owners stopped paying money for architectural features on the outside, they still spent a lot of time investing
最初构想的乌托邦式社区理念在购物中心得以延续。因为如果你身处一个只会让你拖着脚步往前走的空间，比如机场候机楼，你根本不想呆在那里。但如果你身处一个有着美丽自然光、可能还有一个能让你的孩子往里扔硬币的喷泉，或者可能有一张长椅让你在从一家店走到另一家店的间隙稍作休息的空间，你就会在那里呆更长时间。所以，即便购物中心老板不再为外部的建筑特色花钱，他们依然花费大量精力投资
in architectural features and the upkeep of those features on the inside. There's a whole dialogue around maintenance related to the mall. And I think if you look at some pictures of dead and dying malls, like one of the first things you see is like the plants dying, or they've taken all of the plants out of the planters, or there aren't enough trash cans
内部的建筑特色以及对这些特色的维护。围绕购物中心产生了一整套关于维护的对话。我想如果你看一下那些荒废和垂死的购物中心的照片，你会发现最先看到的现象之一就是植物枯萎了，或者花坛里的植物都被拔光了，又或者垃圾桶不够用了。
anymore. And so part of the allure of the mall is of this beautiful and beautifully maintained indoor space that you can go to at any time and the weather will always be perfect. And so like that's where the money goes and that's where I think some of the artistry goes. And I mean, the title of my book is Meet Me By The Fountain
因此，购物中心的魅力有一部分来自于这种美丽且维护得极好的室内空间，你可以随时去那里，而且无论何时天气都永远完美。所以金钱花在了这里，我想一部分艺术美感也倾注于此。我的书名就叫《在喷泉边约我》
because that's also how people orient themselves in malls. Right? Like Meet Me By The Blue Fountain, Meet Me By The Red Fountain, you know. The mall can be a confusing and kind of like jangly place, but these perpetual architecture features help us orient ourselves. After the mall is introduced and it sort of like begins to replicate, then we hit the building boom for malls in the 70s and 80s and then they really begin to change the landscape of America. Could you talk about that time and the sort of rise of the giant mall?
因为这也是人们在购物中心里辨别方向的方式。对吧？比如“在蓝色喷泉边见”、“在红色喷泉边见”，诸如此类。购物中心可能是一个令人眼花缭乱且有点嘈杂的地方，但这些永久性的建筑特色能帮我们辨别方向。在购物中心出现并开始复制之后，我们就迎来了70和80年代购物中心的建设热潮，然后它们真正开始改变美国的景观。你能谈谈那个时代以及巨型购物中心的崛起吗？
The early malls a lot of times are really quite simple. It's just like that I shape or a T shape or a V shape with like one or two or three department stores. And the reason you're going to the mall is to shop, to go to the department store, to maybe get a snack in a snack bar. The food court doesn't actually become part of the mall until the mid 1970s. And then in the 1980s, you begin to get the first wave of boredom with the mall.
早期的购物中心很多时候其实非常简单。它就像是一个“I”字形、“T”字形或“V”字形，只有一两家或三家百货公司。你之所以去购物中心是为了购物，去百货公司，可能顺便在小吃吧吃个快餐。美食广场实际上直到20世纪70年代中期才成为购物中心的一部分。接着在20世纪80年代，人们开始对购物中心产生第一波审美疲劳。
Like people are kind of over the mall. And that's when John Jertie comes in, this LA architect, and he's like, okay, how can we get people to want to go to the mall again? I know we'll put an amusement park in the middle of the mall. And once you put an amusement park in the middle of the mall, it gets exponentially bigger.
人们对购物中心有点腻了。就在那时，这位来自洛杉矶的建筑师约翰·杰蒂登场了，他的态度是：好吧，我们怎么才能让人重新想去购物中心呢？我知道了，我们要在购物中心中间建一个游乐园。一旦你在购物中心中间建了一个游乐园，它的规模就会呈指数级扩大。
And did every mall kind of react in this way? Like I know there's some key ones like Mall of America that has a roller coaster, an aquarium, and stuff like that. Did that effect kind of ripple out into other malls or was it really just confined to a few big ones? The entire amusement park in the mall is really confined to just a few large ones. But the entertainment idea does ripple out.
是不是每个购物中心都以这种方式做出反应？我知道有一些关键的代表，比如拥有过山车、水族馆之类设施的美国商城（Mall of America）。这种效应是否扩散到了其他购物中心，还是真的只限于少数几个大型购物中心？整个购物中心里建游乐园的做法确实仅限于少数几个大型购物中心。但娱乐的理念确实扩散开了。
I mean, you get more and more ice skating rinks in malls. You get bigger and bigger food courts and they get more expressive architecture so that like going to the food court is kind of an event and there are more and more different kinds of cuisines that you can sample. You also get arcades added to malls. So the offerings of malls get broader and broader, and just their square footage gets bigger and bigger. Those malls also are a bigger investment for their developers. So they're trying to pull from a larger and larger area.
我的意思是，购物中心里出现了越来越多的溜冰场。美食广场越来越大，建筑设计也更具表现力，去美食广场本身成了一种活动，你可以品尝到越来越多不同种类的美食。购物中心里也增加了游戏机厅。因此，购物中心的业态越来越广泛，其建筑面积也越来越大。这些购物中心对开发商而言也是更大的投资。因此，他们试图吸引更大范围的客源。
So whereas the original malls were really just trying to serve the suburbs all around them and their quadrant of the city, these new malls are generally referred to as super regional malls. So they are malls that people would really travel to. When you had to get your prom dress, you and your friends would like get in the minivan and go to the mall that was like one or two hours away
所以，最初的购物中心实际上只是为了服务周围的郊区以及他们所在的城市象限，而这些新购物中心通常被称为超区域购物中心。它们是人们愿意大老远专程前往的购物中心。当你要买毕业舞会礼服时，你和朋友们会坐上面包车，去一两个小时车程之外的那个购物中心，
because it had the bigger, better department stores. And you'd spend a whole day there. And it's just a different mentality about shopping and it's a slightly different relationship to the mall itself. This is the San Dimas Mall, and this is where people of today's world hang out. Get in, loser, we're going shopping.
因为它有更大、更好的百货公司。你会在那里度过一整天。这是一种不同的购物心态，也是与购物中心本身略有不同的关系。这里是圣迪马斯购物中心，这也是当今世界的人们闲逛的地方。上车吧，失败者，我们要去购物了。
Let's go to the mall today I went to the mall with a couple of friends I had a whole week to allowance to spend You know, in the 80s during this growth in heyday, the cultural ascendancies of malls, there's a real conflict about the mall as a public space versus a private space. Can you talk about why that's important and what is happening inside of a mall that's different than what would happen if this was a shopping district in a city? As you can tell from the whole mall history,
今天去购物中心吧。我和几个朋友去了购物中心，我有一整周的零花钱可以花。你知道，在80年代的这段发展全盛期，在购物中心文化的鼎盛时期，关于购物中心作为公共空间与私人空间，存在着真正的冲突。你能谈谈为什么这很重要，以及购物中心内部发生的事情与城市里的商业街区有什么不同吗？正如你从整个购物中心的历史中所能看出的，
like, there's been this desire to cast the mall as a community space and hence as a public space, to pretend, at least for a minute, that it's welcoming to everybody, that anyone can go there at any time. But as the malls become bigger and actually start to serve as those de facto public spaces, you run up against the fact that store owners, mall owners, don't really want all the things that can happen in a public space to happen in their mall. And the principle one of those is protests.
人们一直有一种渴望，想把购物中心塑造成一个社区空间，进而塑造成一个公共空间，至少有一会儿假装它是对所有人开放的，任何人随时都可以去。但随着购物中心变得越来越大，并真正开始充当事实上的公共空间时，你就会遇到这样一个事实：商店老板、购物中心老板其实并不希望公共空间里可能发生的所有事情都在他们的购物中心里上演。其中最主要的一项就是抗议活动。
So there start to be this whole series of court cases, basically arguing over whether you can protest in a mall. And the protests that end up serving as the basis for these cases in both the state and federal Supreme Court are over a whole range of issues. Some of them are anti-war protests, some of them are anti-fur protests, some of them are union protests. But in each case, the mall owner asserts that they have the right to eject the protesters from their property because they are not property,
于是开始出现了一系列法庭案件，基本上是在争论你是否能够在购物中心里进行抗议。最终成为州和联邦最高法院这些案件基础的抗议活动，涉及了一系列广泛的议题。其中一些是反战抗议，一些是反皮草抗议，还有一些是工会抗议。但在每一起案件中，购物中心老板都坚称他们有权将抗议者驱逐出他们的私有财产，因为他们不是公共财产，
they don't have to follow free speech rules. And then you get attorneys arguing that if malls are gonna be replaced downtowns, shouldn't they also have to operate like downtowns and let whoever wants to have free speech, have free speech in these properties. One of the earliest cases in 1968, Thurgood Marshall goes before the US Supreme Court
他们不必遵循言论自由规则。然后就会有律师争辩说，如果购物中心要取代市中心，难道它们不也应该像市中心一样运作，让任何想要行使言论自由的人在这些物业里享有言论自由吗？最早的案件之一发生在1968年，瑟古德·马歇尔出庭美国最高法院，
and argues for the majority. And there's this great passage where he basically talks about how the mall has replaced downtown. And I was so fascinated to find that A, it was Thurgood Marshall and B, that he had really articulated the way that Moll's had taken on this public role as early as 1968 in a Supreme Court opinion.
并为多数派进行辩护。其中有一段精彩的论述，他基本上谈到了购物中心是如何取代市中心的。我感到非常着迷的是，第一，这个人是瑟古德·马歇尔；第二，早在1968年的一份最高法院裁决意见中，他就已经明确阐述了购物中心承担这种公共角色的方式。
After that decision, the court gets more and more conservative, and the assertion of free speech rights in Moll's actually gets eaten away until it becomes a state issue. And now, that know, that's something that's actually decided state by state. One of the most recent protests in malls that became a court case was a Black Lives Matter protest at the Mall of America right before Christmas.
在那次判决之后，法院变得越来越保守，购物中心里言论自由权利的主张实际上被不断侵蚀，直到它变成了一个各州自己的问题。现在，你知道，这实际上成了由各州各自裁决的事情。最近在购物中心里引发诉讼的一场抗议活动，是圣诞节前夕在美国商城（Mall of America）发生的“黑人的命也是命”（Black Lives Matter）抗议活动。
During one of the busiest shopping weeks of the year, the Mall of America has caught up in a legal battle with protesters. Four leaders of Black Lives Matter say they received letters on Friday threatening arrests if Wednesday's rally takes place as planned inside the mall. They're trying to force us to say something that, you know, they don't really have the authority to do so.
在一年中最繁忙的购物周之一，美国商城陷入了与抗议者的法律战中。“黑人的命也是命”运动的四位领导人表示，他们周五收到了信件，威胁称如果周三的集会按计划在商场内部举行，将对他们实施逮捕。他们正试图强迫我们说出一些，你知道的，他们根本无权让我们说的话。
This is definitely not only an attack on Black Lives Matter, but on everybody's First Amendment rights and the right to speak out. The protesters like marched in chanting and all of the screens that were installed in the mall around all of these Christmas trees lit up with messages that the protesters had to leave. So it was kind of like you're ruining our like commercial display for Christmas with your protests. You have to think about why did the Black Lives Matter protesters choose the Mall of America? They chose it because there would be people there. There's no point in a protest if you're not going to have people see you and join you
这绝对不仅是对“黑人的命也是命”的攻击，也是对每个人第一修正案权利以及发声权利的攻击。抗议者边走边呼喊着口号进场，商场里围绕着所有圣诞树安装的所有屏幕都亮了起来，显示着抗议者必须离开的信息。所以这有点像是：你们用抗议毁了我们圣诞节的商业展示。你必须思考一下，为什么“黑人的命也是命”的抗议者会选择美国商城？他们选择它是为了那里有人气。如果你不去一个能让人看到你、加入你
and have media coverage. So in a place like Minneapolis in the winter, the concentration of people were going to be at the mall and that's why they wanted to protest there. And I think that's really the rub of all of these court cases. Like if you've evacuated your city and put all of your commercial development in the suburbs,
并获得媒体报道的地方，抗议就毫无意义。因此，在明尼阿波利斯这样的冬日里，人群都会集中在购物中心，这就是他们想在那里抗议的原因。我认为这正是所有这些法庭案件的核心矛盾所在。如果你把城市掏空，把所有的商业开发都放在郊区，
you have to leave space in the suburbs for things to happen that aren't only commercially motivated, like aren't okay with store owners that everybody doesn't agree with. We're past the heyday of the mall now. How many malls have closed and are malls actually dying off? Or like, what are the numbers like? At their peak there were approximately like 2,000 enclosed malls in the U.S. I think that number went down to about 1,500 you know over the past 10 years and people are expecting us to end up like after the pandemic probably around like 800 enclosed malls.
你就必须在郊区留出空间，用来举办不仅仅出于商业动机的活动，比如那些商店老板并不赞同、不是每个人都意见一致的活动。我们现在已经过了购物中心的鼎盛时期。有多少购物中心已经倒闭？购物中心真的在消亡吗？或者说，数据大概是怎样的？在其鼎盛时期，美国大约有2000家封闭式购物中心。我想在过去10年里，这个数字下降到了大约1500家，人们预计大流行之后，封闭式购物中心数量大概最终会降至800家左右。
after the pandemic, probably around like 800 enclosed malls. In the 1990s, which was basically peak mall, there were 140 new malls being built per year. But in 2007, there were zero new malls that were built. People aren't wrong that the mall is dying. Like there is gonna be this huge die-off, but I don't think the mall is going away. I mean, 800 is still still a lot of malls. And many of those are really the big marquee malls
在大流行之后，大概会维持在大约800家封闭式购物中心。在20世纪90年代——基本上是购物中心的巅峰期，每年会新建140家新购物中心。但在2007年，新建的购物中心数量为零。人们认为购物中心正在消亡并不是错的。确实会迎来一波巨大的倒闭潮，但我认为购物中心并没有消失。我的意思是，800家依然数量庞大。其中许多确实是它们所在城镇中
in their towns. In the New York area, it's things like King of Prussia outside Philadelphia, or the mall at Short Hills in New Jersey, or the Westchester up in Yonkers. So the richest malls are surviving. It's really what are typically referred to as Class B and C malls that might have had Sears and other department stores that have now gone out of business that are dying.
的大招牌购物中心。在纽约地区，比如费城郊外的普鲁士国王购物中心，新泽西州的肖特山购物中心，或是扬克斯的韦斯特切斯特购物中心。因此，最富有的购物中心正在生存下来。真正正在消亡的，通常被称为B级和C级的购物中心，它们可能曾拥有西尔斯及其他现已倒闭的百货公司。
And so those are the ones that people film like depressing glamour shots at and also the ones that are potential sites for adaptive reuse. Why, what do you cite is the reason for malls closing? It's a whole bunch of things. We've had this kind of panicky story for years that online retail was gonna destroy bricks and mortar retail. It's actually only 21% of retail
因此，这些就是人们前去拍摄令人沮丧的魅力大片的地方，同时也是适应性再利用的潜在场所。你认为购物中心倒闭的原因是什么？这是多种因素共同作用的结果。多年来，我们一直听到一种恐慌的说法，即在线零售将摧毁实体零售。实际上，即便在现在，它也只占零售额的
sales even now. And the pandemic has accelerated that because more people were doing more internet shopping and, you know, found out that that can be great for a lot of things. But there are still many kinds of shopping that are really better done in person. And even before the pandemic, internet shopping hadn't killed off bricks and mortar retail at the rate that initial dire predictions said it would. So that's part of it. There are also just larger changes in the way we shop. Department stores are no longer the arbiters of taste that they used to be, and more people want
21%。大流行加速了这一趋势，因为更多人开始在网上购物，并且发现这在很多方面确实很棒。但仍有许多类型的购物k方式更适合在线下当面进行。甚至在大流行之前，互联网购物也没有以最初可怕的预测所说的那种速度杀死实体零售。所以这是原因之一。此外，我们购物方式本身也发生了更大的变化。百货公司不再是过去那种品味的仲裁者，越来越多的人倾向于
to shop in smaller stores, even if those aren't necessarily independently owned. And then there's also just a greater income disparity. During the rise of the malls, the American middle class was doing well and growing. And now there is this great disparity between like the upper middle class that's still doing great and the lower middle and working class who have less and less money. And people in those families are much more likely to shop in big-box stores and discount stores because they don't really have the income for a kind of the middle-range stores that used to be the bread and butter of the mall.
在较小的商店购物，即使这些商店不一定是独立所有。然后还有更大的收入差距。在购物中心崛起期间，美国中产阶级状况良好且不断壮大。而现在，状况极佳的上中产阶级与资金越来越少的中下阶层和工人阶级之间存在着巨大的差距。这些家庭的人更有可能去大卖场和折扣店购物，因为他们实在没有足够的收入去光顾过去支撑起购物中心半壁江山的那些中档商店。
It's funny because today there are lots of malls that are now home to employment offices and DMVs. And in a way that's super cool because that's the mixed use idea that was closer to Gruen's original design of the mall. But you write that it's usually a bad sign for the mall when this happens because they've probably given the DMV cheap rent because they're desperate to draw people in. So I mean, this is kind of ironic. Yeah, I mean, that should be a good thing. I think having a DMV and other public services inside a mall would be great. Like think how convenient that would be if you have limited
这很有趣，因为今天有很多购物中心现在成了就业办公室和车管所（DMV）的所在地。从某种程度上说，这非常酷，因为这正是更接近格鲁恩最初设计理念的混合用途构想。但你写道，当这种情况发生时，对购物中心来说通常是个不好的征兆，因为它们可能是把车管所的租金压得很低，因为它们极力想要吸引人流。所以我的意思是，这有点讽刺。是的，我的意思是，这本该是一件好事。我认为在购物中心里设立车管所和其他公共服务机构会非常棒。试想一下，如果你在周末的时间
time on a weekend, you can get all of these things taken care of. And in fact, in the conclusion of my book, I talk about the malls in some other countries, including the Philippines, where many of the malls have a lot of public services just folded into them as a matter of course. My mother volunteers for the Friends of the Durham Public Library and they run a used bookstore and it was one of the businesses in an empty storefront in Northgate Mall in Durham before it closed. So again, city services come in where commercial businesses
有限，能把所有这些事情都一次办妥，该有多方便。事实上，在我的书的结语中，我谈到了其他一些国家的购物中心，包括菲律宾，那里的许多购物中心很自然地就将许多公共服务融入其中。我的母亲是达勒姆公共图书馆之友的志愿者，他们经营着一家二手书店，它曾是达勒姆北门购物中心（Northgate Mall）倒闭前一家空置店面里的商户之一。所以，当商业企业
don't want to pay rent anymore. It's hard for malls to recover from one of their anchored department stores' clothing unless something else big comes in. Is there a way for struggling malls to recover? Is there a formula that actually works? Some malls have been saved or at least stabilized by things like trampoline parks coming in. Again, like that's the entertainment venue.
不再愿意支付租金时，城市服务便进驻了。如果主力百货公司有一家倒闭了，购物中心很难恢复元气，除非有其他大型业态入驻。苦苦挣扎的购物中心有没有办法恢复生机？真的存在某种行之有效的公式吗？一些购物中心通过蹦床公园等的入驻而得以拯救，或者至少实现了稳定。同样的，这也是娱乐场所。
One of the ways that I think malls can survive in the future is through smarter and perhaps more distinct curation of the mall stores. I mean, you know, I know that curation is kind of an overused term, but I think for a long time, malls are getting by on essentially all having the same mix of stores and restaurants, just at different price points. So you'd kind of decide how much money you wanted to spend that day and go to that mall. But going forward, it's easy enough to get inexpensive chain store clothing online. So malls could really distinguish themselves by stocking themselves with things that are
我认为购物中心未来能够生存下去的方法之一，是对商场内的店铺进行更聪明、或许也更独特的策划。我的意思是，我知道“策划”这个词有点被用烂了，但在很长一段时间里，购物中心的生存之道基本上是依靠所有店铺和餐厅的组合都大同小异，只是价格档次不同而已。所以你只需决定那天想花多少钱，然后去对应的购物中心就行了。但展望未来，在网上很容易买到便宜的连锁店服装。因此，购物中心完全可以通过储备那些
all for families. Or I have a couple of examples in the book where malls have turned themselves essentially into like ethnic food and business centers, depending on like the changing nature of their suburb. So, you have like a Latino mall outside Atlanta, or a lot of Asian malls in Northern California that have businesses that are familiar to people from other places but also that they can't get somewhere else and which sell things that they can't get online.
适合家庭的产品来让自己脱颖而出。或者我在书中举了几个例子，购物中心的本质已经转变为类似于民族美食和商业中心的场所，这取决于它们所在的郊区不断变化的面貌。比如，亚特兰大郊外有一个拉丁裔购物中心，北加州有许多亚洲购物中心，里面有来自其他地方的人们所熟悉、但在其他地方买不到的商业，并且出售他们在网上买不到的东西。
When malls do fail and they do close, There's like thousands and thousands of square feet going unused. But you know there aren't a lot of mall shape things that you can put in there after one is gone. What happens with these dead malls? Well a lot of times they just sit there for quite some time because not only do they have these many thousands of square feet that not a lot of entities can deal with, but often they're owned by multiple entities. And so it's not as easy as just like one person selling the mall to one other person. There have been some cases of adaptive reuse where a new business or something has taken over a dead mall. What is the most interesting example of that that you've seen?
当购物中心真的倒闭并关门时，会有成千上万平方英尺的面积闲置不用。但你知道，在商场倒闭之后，并没有太多适合商场这种特定形状的东西可以放进去。这些死去的购物中心后来都怎么样了？嗯，很多时候它们就在那里空置相当长一段时间，因为它们不仅拥有数千平方英尺、没多少实体能处理的大面积空间，而且它们通常由多个实体共同所有。所以这不像一个人把商场卖给另一个人那么简单。有一些适应性再利用的案例，即新的商业或其他机构接管了死去的购物中心。你见过的最有意思的例子是什么？
Highland Mall outside Austin, Texas has been turned over the past decade plus into the leadership campus for Austin Community College. And they turned one of the former department stores into like this huge room full of computers, like workshop space. And they have turned one of the other department stores into the headquarters for Austin Public TV with a lot of internal studio and recording space and an auditorium.
位于德克萨斯州奥斯汀郊外的海兰购物中心（Highland Mall）在过去十多年里被改造成了奥斯汀社区学院的领导力校区。他们把其中一家前百货公司变成了一个摆满电脑的大型房间，用作车间空间。他们还把另一家百货公司变成了奥斯汀公共电视台的总部，里面有大量的内部工作室、录音空间和一个礼堂。
And the parking lot around the mall, some of it they've actually made green open spaces sort of like a regular college campus and around the perimeter they're building housing, some of which can be student housing but other of which can just be affordable rental apartments. It's great if we could reuse these dead malls in some way. People always say that the greenest building is a building that's already built. apartments. It's great if we could reuse these dead malls in some way. Like people
至于商场周围的停车场，其中一部分实际上被改造成了绿色的开放空间，有点像普通的大学校园，而在外围他们正在建造住房，其中一部分可以是学生宿舍，另一部分则可以作为经济型出租公寓。如果我们能以某种方式重复利用这些死去的购物中心，那就太棒了。人们总是说最绿色的建筑就是已经建好的建筑。公寓。如果我们能以某种方式重复利用这些死去的购物中心，就像人们
always say that the greenest building is a building that's already built. How do you feel about it when it comes to reusing malls? I love to see these examples of adaptive reuse. Like when people talk about adaptive reuse they're often thinking about older buildings in cities but at this point malls are older buildings. I mean like many of, malls are older buildings. I mean, like many of the malls that we're talking about that are failing are 50 years old. And I was actually talking to the Chancellor of Austin Community College, and he was saying that lots of people have like very poignant family memories of things that happened in the food
总是说最绿色环保的建筑就是已经建好的建筑一样。当谈到重复利用购物中心时，你作何感想？我非常喜欢看到这些适应性再利用的例子。当人们谈论适应性再利用时，他们通常想到的是城市中的老建筑，但就目前而言，购物中心已经是老建筑了。我的意思是，许多我们谈论的正在走向衰败的购物中心已经有50年的历史了。我实际上曾与奥斯汀社区学院的校长交谈过，他说许多人对那个购物中心的美食
court at that mall. These buildings aren't just buildings in their communities. They're like, A, they're very conveniently located, B, like everyone knows where Highland Mall is because it's been a reference point. And we shouldn't just kind of throw away those memories and throw away that kind of name recognition along with like getting rid of the tremendous like environmental sink of the building materials. So I really see the malls as an opportunity and I would love for people to get more creative about what to do with them.
广场发生的事情有着非常深刻动人的家庭记忆。这些建筑不仅仅是社区里的建筑物。它们是：第一，它们的地理位置非常便利；第二，每个人都知道海兰购物中心在哪里，因为它一直是一个地标。我们不应该仅仅为了摆脱建筑材料带来的巨大环境负担，就把这些记忆和知名度一起扔掉。所以我真的把购物中心视为一种机遇，我希望人们能对如何处理它们发挥更多创造力。
There's a lot of like dead mall photography, which I think can be very beautiful, but it also kind of fixes them in people's minds as these dead entities. And I think kind of like stops the mental process that it takes to then think of, okay, like what are we gonna do with it next? And I mean, I guess coming from a design background,
有很多关于荒废购物中心的摄影作品，我认为它们可以非常美丽，但它们也把购物中心在人们心目中固定为这种死气沉沉的实体。而且我认为这某种程度上阻碍了人们去思考——好吧，我们接下来要拿它怎么办的心理过程。我的意思是，也许由于我的设计背景，
I just see them as an opportunity and a problem and something that could be really fun to think about and something that shouldn't be depressing. But it's like, oh, actually, there's all this new free land in cities. What can we do with it? ["The New World"] Well, this has been so great.
我只是把它们看作是一个机遇、一个问题，以及一件思考起来会非常有趣、绝不应该令人沮丧的事情。但这就像是，哦，实际上，城市里有这么多新的空置土地。我们能用它们做些什么呢？["新世界"] 嗯，这次访谈太棒了。
I've really enjoyed the book too. It was just so much fun to both like learn a lot of stuff and also like have all this information slot into my own sort of like lived experience of a mall. I appreciate it. Thanks for having me. Alexandra Leng's book is called Meet Me By The Fountain, an inside history of the mall. And if you buy the book, which I highly recommend, and you flip it over and look at the back cover, you will find that someone has written, it's an architectural page-turner.
我也真的很喜欢这本书。既能学到很多东西，又能将所有这些信息与我自己在购物中心的生活经验完美契合，这真的太有趣了。我很感激。谢谢你邀请我。亚历山德拉·朗的书名叫《在喷泉边约我：购物中心的内幕历史》。如果你买这本书——我强烈推荐你买，然后把它翻过来看看封底，你会发现有人写道：这是一本让人爱不释卷的建筑类好书。
This insightful, witty, and smart book captures everything compelling and confounding about the American mall. Roman Mars, co-author of The 99% of Visible City. I wrote that for the back of this book. That's how much I believe in this book. You should get it. That episode was produced by Chris Berube, fact-checked by Liz Boyd, music for both stories by Swan Riel.
这本富有洞察力、风趣且聪明的书捕捉到了美国购物中心所有引人入胜又令人困惑的特质。《可见城市的99%》共同作者罗曼·马尔斯。我为这本书的封底写了这段话。可见我对这本书有多么笃信。你应该买一本。那一集由克里斯·贝鲁布制作，丽兹·博伊德核实事实，两个故事的音乐均由斯旺·里尔创作。
This whole episode was produced and remixed by Martin Gonzalez, who actually grew up in Providence. He was scooping ice cream at the Ben & Jerry's and the mall's food court in 2003. All while this was happening, yet somehow was completely unaware of it until he heard the original 99PI story. Kathy Tuas, our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director.
整集节目由马丁·冈萨雷斯制作和混音，他其实是在普罗维登斯长大的。2003年，他在购物中心美食广场的本杰瑞冰淇淋店挖冰淇淋。这一切都在发生着，然而直到他听到最初的99PI故事之前，他对此却全然不知。我们的执行制片人是凯茜·图。库尔特·科尔斯坦是数字总监。
D'Laney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lashma Dawn, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building.
德兰尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。其余团队成员包括杰森·德莱昂、埃met特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·雷、拉什马·唐、约瑟夫·罗森伯格、凯利·普莱姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。99%的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们现在是SiriusXM播客大家庭的一部分，总部设在北边六个街区外的潘多拉大楼。
InBeautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find us on Blue Sky as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
位于美丽的上城。加利福尼亚州奥克兰。你可以在Blue Sky以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。在 99PI.org 上可以找到相关链接以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。